deux côtés une vingtaine de militants
rouge vert noir de l'autre le président
de l'exécutif et ses soutiens de partis
opposés et qui pourtant revendiquent
tous deux le soutien du peuple
martiniquais et j'ai pu choquer le
peuplement
[Musique]
on a répondu en masse si des placards
pour se marier aulas alors
instrumentalisation ou simple expression
des divergences d'avis dans les rues de
fort-de-france ce matin les réactions
sont effectivement variés et à les
hibiscus le plus choisi les discussions
le teaser c'est pas mal quand même voix
les deux boules rondes de l'ambient les
étoiles ça va vous présenter chaque
département d'outre-mer par rapport à
leur différend
drapeau choisi ses bas récemment c'est
pourquoi il valait mieux avoir un petit
colis bus à la place
ça représente seulement voilà il a
décidé défunt de la pop roues quand on
va au compteur soit présente dans la
caraïbe pour le sport un drapeau sur
tout ça tout à fait normal
je me demande pourquoi ils veulent
brûlures de la peau qui n'a rien la
politique la polémique en tout cas
provoqué un regain d'attachement drapeau
rouge vert noir comme chez ce commerçant
qu'il exhibe désormais devant son
magasin de notre côté douze mille trois
cents personnes ont bien voulu se prêter
au jeu du vote à l'issue du concours
lancé par la ctm
mais dans un cas comme dans l'autre
peut-on alors parler d' adhésion
populaire
est ce que le drapeau qui a été
sélectionné et un drapeau qui
majoritairement est légitime ou est ce
que finalement ce sont et puis qui a
voté comme surtout quand on fait voter
les gens par internet qu'ils sont ces
gens
tu n'es pas parce que je n'ai pas voté
que je ne fais pas partie du peuple
je n'ai pas parce que je ne suis pas
d'accord que je ne fais pas partie du
peuple
justement je trouve qu'il manque le
consensus autour de ça pour essayer de
trouver quelque chose d'un peu plus
prégnant peu plus ressemblants notre
identité un peu plus
qui par la puce à chacun quoi qu'il en
soit depuis son officialisation le
drapeau a déjà fait l'objet de plusieurs
barreaux 10 sur les réseaux sociaux
la polémique est visiblement loin d'être
terminée